huh
i think it was here
okay waiting
glad you're here oh i need your help
cooking hi
what's on the menu jambalaya come on
um soy meat okay
this is an ancient ward family secret
uh-huh
onions paprika thyme i just need to
mince some celery and garlic
but you stir please stir i'm stirring
i'm stirring
that my socks you've never had better
jump a liar
[Music]
how's uh randy holding up
he's looking for his old self
physically though it'll be a long road
before he's back to full health
and uh mentally that was
some experience what harris did to him
[ __ ] as this might sound might have
helped the kid
could be wrong but feels like a clean
brain it'll spoil a nice day
but i gotta ask
what about peter pan you're asking if i
killed him
we'll talk later okay sure no pressure
it's just i uh you know
i know
all right i think you've stirred enough
mind grabbing the rice from the kitchen
yes sir
no randy's always been that way but i'm
sure this didn't help none
you know his father was a difficult man
too
there's maddie nice how you doing joss
i'll call you back later
[Music]
tomatoes are next now you can toss in
the rice
rice is in okay now this has to bubble
and brew
patio
grab a chair and uh beer or something
else
it's nice out here yeah
seems all good like nothing bad ever
happened
tell me now about harris
i paid him a visit at the hospital
you flatline him
i wasn't sure that was what i really
wanted
one shot to the head quick and clean
i had the same thought it would be so
easy
i pressed the gun to his head and
remembered something
river and my parents died
oh sure you want to hear this
what happened old man had a farm
like harris is dead but when business
took a turn
well
my parents managed to open a small
grocery
we lived on the floor above
a loud noise woke us one night
they wanted cash register was empty so
they stormed upstairs
forced us all to kneel and demanded my
dad tell him where he hid the money
[Music]
mostly i remember my mom crying
when my dad swore they'd found all we
had
one was gassed out of his mind
he fired first blew half my dad's skull
off
jesus river i'm sorry
it was erratic when rabid
handed me his gun and ordered me to aim
it at my mom's head
i could still see her tear-filled eyes
at the end of that barrel to this day
what did you do nothing
i stood frozen finally he just snatched
the gun back
shot my mother and they left police
never caught him
[Music]
that was why i joined the force i
couldn't agree with scum like that roman
free
no one telling him
i was just there too saw all this
i think when she looks at me
she still sees that boy holding a gun to
her mom's head
can't tell you how sorry i am
[Music]
so when i stood over harris in that
hospital bed
apparel to his brow i was that kid again
but i was also the junkie who shot my
parents
i understand i've ended a few lives in
my time
but never like that never an execution
slipped out of the hospital quick told
myself the case was closed
that's good but what now you're not
going back to the pd pi
has a nice ring to it who knows
uncle river you said you'd play with us
you promised
all right all right let's go
hey join us what are we gonna play
uncle river you'll see
dorian we're playing yeah big trouble in
hate one grab yourself
well what do you think
always wanted to try a game like this
well well
nice firepower there this is no time to
get distracted
we can't let that filth get away who oh
well look at you v allow me to introduce
captain joan mclean and lieutenant henry
callahan
there are precincts best and brightest
wouldn't want to get in their way
i always work alone no exceptions
even for you yeah me too
all right let's get to it right
all we got to do is track down diablado
and take out his lackeys along the way
he'll
pay for his crimes
we play like two teams us and the kids
but we work toward the same objective
the team with the best result
wins you don't stand a chance
av just go easy okay it's their favorite
game
sure
[Music]
oh there he is get him the city is mine
you'll never take her from me
[Laughter]
he's fast but not fast enough to escape
justice watch out
their rat infested hideouts i could
smell the moral decay from a mile off
[Music]
quiet too quiet
it's a trap they were waiting for us
not that bad
he did he did okay that's all of them
but next time we gotta be faster
ah [ __ ]
obstructing justice is punishable by law
this is your last warning easy there
captain
i'm just passing through
too many donuts not done yet
don't worry about me
not half that hey i have better aim
[Music]
too many donuts okay not done yet
but it's not over yet
some last words fine
out with it scumbag i want to see you
squirm
no your last words
oh come on another ambush
okay so now lunch is ready um
we almost had him oh you'll get him next
time
at least we meet the grown-ups we're the
best
thanks for letting them win they had fun
wow they're great kids it's no problem
seems they took a liking to you two
hey food's on the table
so was your game fun
awesome we kicked their big butts
the bad guys huh oh yeah the bad guys
too
time to see if this tastes as good as it
smells unemployment's being good to you
you seem good river's discovering the
joys of family life
that and police duty never a good mix
this here's a way to get some of those
years back
i haven't seen him this untroubled
in a while what about you v
you got a family or just relations
grew up in haywood whole street was my
family
neighbors helped each other out thought
nothing of it
nothing's more important to me than my
kids i've made mistakes
life's gone off the rails sometimes but
i had my kids
i got my kids
joss you see me being a parent ever
i mean i don't exactly look like good
paw material myself
so yes who says yes i do
he raised his hand himself
v have you seen someone involved
fess up please um
well that's decided
got an 11.99 officer needs backup
come on pull you out of this ambush
thanks joss yeah thanks
situation was getting dicey that's what
partners are for
you were about a hair's breath away from
having to look at photo albums
you just getting out of doing the dishes
admit it
also true which gives us two reasons to
go
here we are what are we looking at
a water tower great spot
great for what having a drink
shooting the [ __ ]
this way [ __ ] gate's stuck again
gotta fix it one of these days let me
give you a boost
climb over hoping it from the other side
no need whoa okay
we like leaping just push
seems easier to open okay
on our way
there he's not bad actually unlikely to
dazzle
make a good first impression though
certainly no corporal plaza
no the life's livable here
know what worse places to raise kids
randy's problems with the law
those didn't pop out of thin air true
but randy takes after his old man he'd
find trouble in a nicer neighborhood too
apparently the worst city between the
atlantic and the pacific
but i sure do love this view find it
calming
great spot indeed
told you got something for you
your peace let her a long time
too long i think it's time she found a
new owner
to know what to say just
promise you won't blow your foot off
oddly specific request
josh's husband did it drunk this very
spot
which made this your special spot family
landmark
some other kind
now for the highlight of the evening up
for a drink
something strong's sure to hit the spot
now that i understand
[Music]
to friendship
to friendship
got any more that two bottles of whiskey
in a case of beer ought to be enough
we'll see about that buckle your liver
in
gonna be a long night and a longer
[Music]
morning
[Music]
[Music]
psycho attacks over the last decade the
number of incidents has increased as
much as 43 percent
lamar colonizing the moon
and there's still no cure for hangovers
well
at least we had fun yesterday yeah
but no i gotta roll promise josh i'd
take her to see randy
no rush either get your seat legs back
take as much time as you need urging
european governments to restore
sure you're good to drive please
former ncpd i'm a pro on hangover
highway
i'll be fine
apologize to joss for me we kind of
dined and dashed yesterday i left puke
all over the bathroom
oh [ __ ]
tell randy hey see you later v